Thank you for having having me.
My name is Alvaro Videla.
I'm from Uruguay.
I work as an engineer on a SQL database.
Please visit the websites so my manager knows
I'm here!
[Laughter].
I wrote this article laugh year which got
100,000 visits.
Basically explaining my story on how I got
into programming.
Ten years ago, I was basically selling food
in the streets in the countryside of Uruguay.
But this talk is called metaphors we compute
by and you can read it on the ACMQ website,
and the communications of the ACM.
The year is 1980, one year earlier for me
being born.
There is a book published called Metaphors
We Live By, so you can tell the title of my
talk is nothing original, it is a copy of
that ing, because this work was so influential
that, after it came, metaphors we socialise
by, so, this work the idea was to study the
brain because they would scientists, but you
cannot go and open people's brains and see
what is there inside.
That's kind of illegal — it tends to be.
So they say, okay, try to understand the brain,
by using a proxy, which is language.
And they found out that metaphor isn't just
a matter of poetry, like rhetoric al flourish.
Metaphors dictate how we think, behave, how
we perceive, and how our conceptual system
is built.
To give you an example, the first from their
book, they say argument is war.
War is a metaphor in which we frame argument.
I think this is kind of in line with the previous
talk.
Why people have these flame wars on the internet?
If we think of argument as war, we will say
things like, "Your claims are indefensible."
"He attacked every weak point in my argument.
I demolished his argument.
I never won an argument with him.
His criticisms were right on target."
The point being, because of this framing of
as a war, we literally tried to destroy the
other person.
And they ask in this book, asked like what
if argument will be dance which is a kind
of metaphor using, and then thinking about
arguments, because we need to collaborate
together to reach a common goal, and then
maybe a metaphor would be you should not be
stepping on my toes or something like that.
It will be a more collaborative thing.
But I can see your favourites that you're
not convinced.
When people are not convinced, we talk about
politics, right?
There was a really nice article from the BBC
called How metaphors Shape Women's Lives,
but but it talked about all this glass-ceiling
metaphor, what not, how you're stopped from
progressing at companies, but for me, even
more interesting in that article, was this
research done where they grabbed a group of
student, and they tell them there is a wild
beast preying on the city.
Crime is a wild beet preying on the city.
The other they say that a virus is infecting
the city.
Both groups get the same data, statistics
and so on.
They have a different framing metaphor.
When people are asked what are the solutions
they propose, 75 per cent of the beast students,
they wanted to put people in jail and do strong
punishments.
The people in the virus case wanted to help
the other and help them, improve, progress,
and so on.
When they asked them why did you choose that
kind of punishment, or why do you want to
kill people, get better, and so on?
They say, "Because the data says so."
None of them realised they were primed with
a particular metaphor.
There is also a book from the 1980s called
Feminism Confronts Technology, and it's really
good if you want to have a deep dive into
feminist point of view into technology.
And it is like how the words "hard" and "soft
"have been changing across the history of
technology.
At some point, intellectual work was not considered
interesting, whatever, and the machos out
there deemed the work soft, and suddenly,
we have computers, so all this macho mentality
brought the "hard" word into programming with
these aggressive metaphors, like you need
to be coding 24/7, pushing for that release,
about your stamina, and so on.
She said no matter how masculinity is defined,
it always construes women as ill-suited to
technological pursuits.
Language is also important, even if how we
approach different groups if you want to make,
for example, technology frame there for women,
friendly for women or other groups like in
Latin America, for example.
Still not convinced?
Human resource management.
If you think with this metaphor, you will
think that the same way that you replace a
hard drive on a server, you replace a programmer
on your team, and there are many managers
that think this way, but we need to understand
that people are not resources, like we are
not here ... [Cheering].
We bring more to the world that can be replaced.
We build interpersonal relationships, organise
things to happen in certain times, and so
on.
We are very rich living beings.
Finally, giving platform to racist people.
There is a conference in the United States,
I won't name them, that they like to have
keynoters, like racist people.
Last year, the keynoter, was one that considered
women to be inferior, and so on.
When the community came against this conference,
and they criticised them for having a racist
person as a keynoter, they wrote a blog post,
and it was called "wrestling with inclusion"
at whatever the name of that conf.
I wonder "wrestling".
Why do you need to wrestle with inclusion?
Why can't you have a dialogue or talk with
people involved in these communities?
No, they decided to wrestle very, "I'm going
to beat you down", right?
I guess you're here to talk about computers,
right?
So computers: have you seen the movie "hidden
figures" where this astronaut from the States,
this the black women helped put a man, an
American in space, the Russians had done that
already?
They were doing calculation.
They were doing computing by hand.
So these women were called computers.
But at some point, we had this very fast electronic
machine that was doing what they were doing
really fast, so how do we call those things
that do what these people are already doing,
okay?
Automatic computers.
The automatic word was dropped, and now we
just call them computers.
Why is this?
Because metaphors, they enable understanding.
When we don't know how to talk about something,
we probably will use some sort of a metaphor.
I don't remember yesterday if you give me
a second, I was watching a talk here about
simulation for blind people, he said additional
screen real estate that you account for.
Now there is real estate that we account for.
This is a metaphorical way of understanding
what is going on that is just the screen is
bigger and we need to do something with that
bigger screen.
But when I say the metaphor to enable understanding,
the typical metaphor is from Shakespeare,
that says Juliet is like the sun.
And we need to understand that metaphors aren't
a one-to-one mapping between source domain
and target domain.
Metaphors just illuminate some areas so we
understand what is meant but Juliet means
for Romeo in this case, his life depends on
her.
He resolves around her all day, he thought,
whatever.
She is the light of his life.
We don't think Juliet gave him skin cancer
because we are smart enough to understand
that metaphors are not a one-to-one mapping,
like Juliet is not an atomic bomb walking
around Italy, right?
There is a book by a guy I think from either
the Netherlands or Belgium, called the Geometry
of Meaning, semantics based on conceptual
spaces.
Long story short: somebody got paid in Europe
for doing geometry research of language.
These things in South America don't happen.
We try to make sure that our cows make better
meat, basically!
In that book, it is really interesting because
he said that metaphorical mappings preserve
the cognitive topology of the source domain
in a way that is consistent with inherent
structure of the target domain, so, source,
sun, target, Juliet.
Metaphor transfers information from one conceptual
domain to another, and what is transferred
is a pattern rather than domain-specific information.
Juliet is not giving you cancer, and a metaphor
can thus be used to identify structure in
a domain that will not have been discovered
otherwise.
So that is the power that metaphor brings
us when we need to understand how the world
actually works.
And, for me, I stole this animation from that
link town there, this is what we are doing
in a way with our brain, with metaphors.
We're doing like a problem that we solve constantly
when we're able to apply a method in a context
that has nothing to do with it.
This is how metaphors create new knowledge.
But the problem with metaphors is that they
also obscure understanding.
Back in the 18th century when they tried to
create the telegraph, the metaphor was the
"far writing" tele graph.
Because of this metaphor, they were so tied
to the metaphor, this they would create a
device that would write remotely instead of
[unclear] having something like Morse code
or whatever, because Morse code was not a
thing, thanks to — they started encoding
on language, our language, in a different
code that is not the one that we use for speaking,
humanity realised like okay, we can trust
that we talk in a different way before Morse
code, before telegraph, we hadn't realised
as a species or society that we could do these
things with language.
In this book The Shadows said sometimes our
tools do what we tell them to, but otherwise,
we adapt ourselves to our tool's requirements.
We need to be careful with this.
We're today adapted to having a phone and
Twitter every day, let's say.
Or back in the day when people invented this
in Switzerland.
I'm sure it wasn't invented in Switzerland
but I live there so I need to say these kinds
of things!
Before people didn't live by the second or
the minute, whenever the church bell rang
before the going to mass, or whatever this
be , they knew they had to gather at the town
square, or something like that, but it wasn't
like they were clocking every single thing.
This is also, for example, I learned in London,
like this is why they know the exact locations
when Jack the Ripper was doing things because
there are so many churches in London, that
they were hearing the bells, so after this
many bells, Jack the Ripper did something
somewhere.
That was a way of tracking time back then.
Today, we're totally adapted to having this
super precise information.
Metaphors are the tools of thought, so, going
back to the beginning of the talk, depending
on the metaphors we use, it's how we understand
the world around us.
And also, how we can understand code.
This paper, no-one knows who wrote this paper,
it would be to me is the best unknown paper.
It is from back in the 1960s, if I'm not mistaken.
And they say to programme is to write to another
parameter about our solution to a problem.
So programming is forget about the computer,
it's just a tool, what we are doing with programmes
is communicating ideas, communicating solutions.
And, as they say also in the structure and
interpretation of computer programmes, programmes
must be written for people to read, and only
incidentally for machines to execute.
And this is not something new.
If we go back to the 1955/54, David Wheeler
from England, he invented the sub routine,
because that's what people in do in England,
they invent sub routines and computers, stuff
like that.
Anyway, at the end of the paper, he says that
there is no need for the sub routine when
you have assembly code, because the above
remarks might be summarised by saying sub
routines are useful but not absolutely necessary,
and that the thing to be borne in mind when
won instructing them is simplicity of use,
correctness of code.
All complexity shall be, if possible, be buried
out of site.
Yes, there is no need for a sub routine.
There is no need for refactoring code.
But because we are communicating between people,
we want make sure we understand what they
Waugh in that particular problem.
By the way, this woman here, this is a picture
from a book that David Woolly wrote because
he wrote the first programming back in 1956
maybe or earlier, and this is the first programmer
ever pictured in a programming book.
So there you go with your — anyway — machitos
are the only ones programming.
If you look at the text below.
Look at the text back then that were not metaphors.
She has a library of tapes where the sub routines
are punched, that was a natural library of
sub routines like some paper thing that they
will punch into the machine.
I don't even know.
Everything we talk is metaphorical in a way.
You will see more later.
But metaphors and code.
In code, I say that types are the characters
telling the story of your programmes, but
for the Haskell people cheering behind, chillax,
because I'm not talking about those — data
types by Barbara Liskov.
She had to fight, you know this that we have
today on, if it was Twitter times, she was
full of those telling her that you don't need,
the construction was wrong, because they were
already in the post-war of go-to, and they
managed to move away from go-do in 1964, and
so on, so in 1974, but we also can do instruction,
and people were all fighting against her ideas.
But the problem is is that if we don't have
types, we just have operations on a stream
of bytes.
So let's talk about choosing the right data
structure.
We have a problem where we needed, for example,
to count or to keep somewhere all the people
that came to the JSConf EU.
You can use an array that works perfectly.
Put everybody inside there — fine.
If you use a metaphor that has a meaning,
it is telling you that that bunch of whatever
it is, in this case of users, those users
have to be unique, so just like changing the
data type, you're telling me a lot of information
about how you solve your programme.
If you use a living list, you're telling me
you can traverse this in this way but you
can do inserts however you want.
If you have a queue, you're telling me, first
in, first out.
Stuck the reverse operation.
Because a programme, explanatory power, is
the measure of its own elegance.
If your programme can't explain what we are
trying to do, can't satisfy the initial goal.
The data structures, they have explanatory
power that can give us cognitive lips.
For example, scaling.
We want to be able to serve food based on
the order in which people arrive at the counter,
and blah, and their country's food, maybe
we need to bring another person to — too
boring, but if we start talking about queuing
theory, we understand this is a problem in
queuing theory, not only we have a bunch of
languages to talk about that problem, there's
a whole theory of queuing that was developed
by airlines back in the 1930s for telecommunications,
and we can base analysis of the problem on
actual mathematical theory.
The same here: how do I get from here to Tegel
Airport?
Number one, don't take the bus!
You can try to guess and try many things,
but at some point, you will know, you have
a graph theory problem here.
With there, we have the mathematics to solve
this.
By the way, not only that map is not a map
of the territory — if you have heard that
sentence — the graph is a metaphor of that
territory, and that graph is enabling you
to do things to the territory, and also it's
for forbidding you to do things with the territory,
so that metaphor of the graph in graph theory
and maps is what I was saying before: it has
constraining powers.
But I think the most interesting example from
the replication.
They tried to build an algorithm to spread
data using rumour-mongering, basically.
I am a computer, I have some data, I say to
this computer, and this other computer, and
then this computer spread the rumour to other
computers, and so on, like a Latin American
TV novella, the way to spread rumours.
This is the way we spread the word.
The problem is really easy to explain with
this metaphor but it is really hard to reason
of about the correct ness of the algorithms.
But they saw that this also mapped to epidemics,
and, an epidemic, there is a book that is
the mathematical fear from the 1940s and 1950s,
using the math in that book to prove their
algorithm will spread the data to all those
in the replication because they understood
another metaphor, the same way an epidemic
goes through a population is how you can send
data through a bunch of nodes.
And is everything a metaphor, then, like this
is what you're trying to say?
Yes.
Actually, when I was watching this film, I
heard her saying, "Metaphors be with you"
because I was so in this thing.
Did she really say metaphors be with you?
Yes, she did!
Everything is a metaphor.
I don't believe you, I just read one slide,
because I don't have much time.
This is the distributed system literature.
Whenever nosed needs to agree on a common
value, we start a consensus algorithm to — there's
usually a leader process that takes care of
making the final decision based on the vote
it was it has received from its peers.
We send messages on a channel, the channel
gets congested, too much traffic, we get bottlenecks,
and so on, and end up with partitions, and
the response of the computer — is it dead?
This is all metaphorical language, and there
are more metaphors there than I want to bore
you with.
Yes, when we don't know how to explain something,
we use metaphorical language all the time.
Yes, it is time that we don't talk any more
about master-slave.
Take it out.
It's very, very easy!
[Applause].
Let's talk about passwords.
You know this one, right?
Containers.
I was wondering why containers picked up so
much?
If we think about containers like the actual
physical cache, it is a standard thing that
can be shipped anywhere, fits on trains, ships,
and trucks.
You can stack and reuse them, and so on.
It is a very good language to speak about
this thing I'm trying to build or sell you.
I wonder at some point if people will have
a start-up to recover from shipping containers,
I don't know.
But another password is microservices.
When I read this blog post ... isolation collaboration,
small is better, big is cumbersome, David
versus Goliath, whatever, when you read the
next, you say this is Erlang.
I don't know if any of you worked in Erlang?
But, I was like, these guys literally stole
everything from he recall Lang and gave them
a new name in the very last paragraph on the
footnote, it says, "In another direction,
one could argue that microservices are the
same thing as the Erlang model but applied
to an enterprise application context" are
you crying little Erlang boy because I don't
use Erlang?
My yes is what it Erlang's elevators' pitch.
These are the metaphors in Erlang: kill children,
you spawn children.
You have supervisors on those children, and
the actor model, what is even the actor model?
Imagine trying to sell Erlang with this type
of vocabulary.
Very hard.
First, get people to understand things, and
then explain how things actually work.
For example, RabbitMQ, a server, also a developer
advocate.
When people ask me this question, I say no,
it's not, it's a Q server.
A message is a higher attraction than jobs.
You can do — it is a job server, yes, understand
rabbit, with that metaphor, and then we can
go deeper to see what it actually is.
Conclusion: we need to master the art of metaphor
selection, we need to master the art of meaning
amplification, and, finally, our programme
is a metaphor for the solution we found.
If you want references, some of the books
I read, some of the pictures I stole from
the internet.
Thank you.
[Cheering and Applause].
I want to say thanks to the organisers, because
it's not objective that you see a conference
where Latinos are not only serving food, they
are speaking, they are there in the crowd,
so, thanks!
[Applause].